[Music]
in the very heart of his novel to
android's dream of electric sheep philip
k dick
has rick deckard the main character
entering into a
fake police station that he is
having presented to him as if it's not
just a real police station but as the
real police station
the
mission street hall of justice as
opposed to his lambert street hall of
justice where he goes every morning at
work
and reports in and does his his business
and so there's a a lot going on here in
chapters 10 and 11 even chapter 9 where
the
lead up to this is happening and there's
two passages that we should start with
when we're talking about this
doppelgangering
not just of individuals but of an entire
police station so
first is at the beginning of chapter 10
the mission street hall of justice
building onto the roof of which the
hover car descended jutted up in a
series of baroque ornamented spires
complicated and modern the handsome
structure struck rick deckard as
attractive
except for one aspect
he had never
seen it before
and so he starts reflecting right
it makes no sense he said to himself who
are these people and if this place has
always existed
why didn't we
know about it and why don't they know
about us two parallel police agencies he
said to himself ours and this one but
never coming into contact as far as i
know until now
or maybe they have he thought maybe this
isn't the first time hard to believe he
thought
that this wouldn't have happened long
ago if it really is a police apparatus
here if that's what it asserts itself to
be
and then we find that
inspector garland
the person in charge of that office is
going to say as he brings in phil resch
another bounty hunter
says i don't think you understand the
situation this man
or android rick deckard comes to us from
a phantom hallucinatory non-existent
police agency
allegedly operating out of the old
departmental headquarters on lombard
he's never heard of us
and we've never heard of him
he employs a test we've never heard of
the list he carries around isn't of
androids it's a list of human beings
he's already killed once at least once
and if miss luft hadn't gotten to a
phone he probably would have killed her
and then eventually he would have come
sniffing around after
me
so the question here is like well
who's the android whose memories can
actually be
relied upon who has the
truthful
perception understanding
experience within
the world and who's who's the real cop
right so
this is a
serious issue now i should point out
that none of this
happens within the film adaptation
the blade runner right this is
completely
left out
and what ends up happening
in chapter 9 is that deckard is trying
to administer the void camp empathy test
to
the opera singer android le belluff to
prove that she's an android this is
after he's already
killed another android who's in his car
and so he's trying to fulfill his
bounties and she finds ways to subvert
the test you know she pretends like she
doesn't understand english very well and
uses that linguistic barrier and then
her own
incomprehension and curiosity about the
test to try to keep him from being able
to administer it and then as he begins
to to do so she pulls out a laser tube
points it at him and calls the cops
now deckard is happy to have the cops
called he's like yeah they'll verify for
you that i'm actually a bounty hunter
that i'm doing my legitimate duty here
and that everything is on the proverbial
up and up so what what ends up happening
is this this cop a harness bull or as we
would say a beat cop right shows up
officer crams and officer crams is kind
of a no-nonsense fellow he wants to know
what's going on here and you know take
statements from from both and when
deckard says listen i'm i'm a fellow
policeman
let me get my inspector on the phone and
you can talk to him he's able to call
and he's able to get bryant on the phone
and then when he hands the phone off to
officer crams the video screen is blank
and cram says there's nobody on this
line
i don't know what's going on but buddy
i'm taking you in and so
uh deckard is like yeah let's let's go
to the uh police office and we'll get
this all straightened out and uh this
will be you know this will be good we'll
finish this up and then
they get in the patrol car and start
heading south and he says something was
not as it should be officer kramz had
steered the car in the wrong direction
the hall of justice rick said is north
on lombard that's the old hall of
justice officer kram said the new one is
on mission that old building it's
disintegrating it's a ruin nobody's used
it for years has it been that long since
you last got booked
and rick says take me there to lombard
street he understood it all
now saw what the androids working
together had achieved he would not live
beyond this ride for him it was the end
and so he's already like suspicious of
these people
androids right he knows that there's
something going on and then he arrives
at the beginning of chapter 12 gets
booked and inspector garland takes him
aside and they have a couple different
uh conversations
so the first thing is
uh he says what do you have in in this
briefcase mr deckard and rick says
material pertaining to the voigt camp
personality test i was testing a suspect
when officer crams arrested me the
questions i asked miss loved are
standard vk questions and then uh
garland says do you know george gleason
and phil resch
rick says no and then he says
well they're the bounty hunters
for northern california both are
attached to our department maybe you'll
run into them while you're
here
and rick tries calling his wife
reaches a woman he's never seen before
um
and then
the the inspector garland is going to
say here's your briefcase i'd like to
talk with you further come on into my
office what's this test that you're
using and they go back and forth talking
about
the different tests that they use and
then he says
look i'm i'm checking out your
assignments here
it looks like i'm on your list this is
rather
disconcerting
um
and he says i'm going to get phil resh
let's bring him
into this
and so then they they start having a
further conversation about
matters
and so
garland himself is listed as one of the
androids now something very interesting
is going to happen
with the androids in their
conversations
with deckard and also to a certain
extent uh in relation to phil resh as
well the other bounty hunter so loboluft
officer crams and inspector garland are
each going to suggest to deckard
that he is
actually an android
and the
shortest one is the harness bull right
who um
says maybe you're an android with false
memories like they give them had he ever
thought of that he grinned frigidly as
he continued to drive south and this is
after deckard says listen buddy
you're an android
uh and
this is gonna be a lot of big trouble
here right so he's he's just kind of
like following through on stuff
garland is going to suggest something
different he says
are you an android mr deckard the reason
i ask
is that several times in the past we've
had escaped andes turn up posing
as out-of-state bounty hunters here in
pursuit of a suspect so
he's giving him something a bit more
plausible a bit more particular you
could have false memories deckard
and think that you're actually a bounty
hunter when you're not
now libel luft is the one who's actually
got the most sophisticated
pitch for him
and
[Music]
it arises first with a discussion about
androids and their relation to each
other so she says i'm not an android um
do you have information there's an
android in the cast i'd be glad to help
you and if i were an android would i be
glad to help you and deckard says
an android doesn't care what happens to
another android that's one of the
indications we look for and then she
says something really startling well
then you must be an android
that stopped him he stared at her
because she continued your job is to
kill them isn't it you're what they call
a bounty hunter rick said but i'm not an
android and then she
brings in another consideration this
test you want to give me
have you taken it and he says yes a long
long time ago when i first started with
the department
maybe that's a false memory don't
android sometimes go around with false
memories and rick says my superiors know
about the test it's mandatory and then
she says
maybe there was once a human who looked
like you and somewhere along the line
you killed him
and took his place and your superiors
don't know
she also suggests i'll take the test
after you take the test and says listen
lady you you can't give the test so
we're going to get on with this and
that's when she you know pulls the laser
tube and the harness bowl shows up and
all that so each of them are suggesting
that deckard himself
is not just a hunter of androids but an
android himself so there's something
kind of contradictory about this he's
mixed up and this is a way for them the
androids to try to trip up the human
being and now
we should talk about phil resch
because he
emerges in
chapter 10 right he's one of the other
bounty hunters
and garland uh calls phil rush to come
in and he introduces them he says you're
both bounty hunters and it's probably
time you met
and uh resh says which city are you
attached to garland answered for rick
san francisco take a look at a schedule
this one comes up next
and then resh says segar this this is
you
and he says there's more he's also got
lobo luff the opera singer there on his
lift of retired list of retirement
assignments and
palakkov remember paulakov he's now dead
this bounty hunter or android or
whatever he is got him and we're running
a bone marrow test at the lab to see if
there's any conceivable basis now here's
where phil resh says something
interesting
it says polikov i've talked to that big
santa claus from the soviet police i
think it is a good idea to run a bone
marrow test on him and garland says why
it's just to remove any legal basis on
which this man deckard could claim he
hasn't killed anyone he'd only retired
an android and rash says
polikov struck me as cold extremely
cerebral and calculating detached and
garland says well a lot of the soviet
cops are that way
and
rush continues on and says you know
ever since i first met paulakoff i
wanted to test him but no pretext ever
arose it never would have either
which is one of the values
such a spot would have for an
enterprising android now what kind of
spot
he a little bit earlier he says
i've always said the best place for an
android would be with a big police
organization right why because
they would be
you could say the the administers of the
test rather than the ad ministered
and they're the ones who have the
monopoly on
force
so
you know it would make sense that an
android would want to infiltrate
and this is where garland says i don't
think you understand the situation
and um
uh phil resh you know says well garland
says have you wanted to test me too
a discreet smile traveled across phil
resh's face he started to answer and
then shrugged he did not seem afraid of
his superior despite garland's palpable
wrath right
and um you know he's going to leave and
go and get his own
test to administer
to
inspector garland the bonnelli reflex
arc test and he says i've said for years
it should be applied routinely to police
personnel the higher up the chain of
command the better and garland says yeah
i've always opposed that on the basis of
you know bad for morale
and then
uh rick says well i think you're gonna
have to sit still for it
because pop polokov turns out to be an
android
and so then um you know
we we get into this interesting
conversation after phil rush leaves and
garland says
man
this is going to be a mind blower
okay i'm i'm an android god you got me
there
but
resh doesn't know
he's also an android
so exactly what they've been suggesting
is the case for deck art which isn't the
case for decart at all by the way as a
side note a lot of write-ups of the
difference between the film the blade
runner and the novel the android's dream
of electric sheep say well the novel
hints that deckard himself might be an
android no it's androids that hint that
deckard might be an android actually
don't hint at it suggest it strongly and
the novel rejects that entirely right
and it's also going to reject phil resh
himself being an android although
garland is claiming
that resh is an android and they're
trying to put that sort of
suspicion into both of their heads
about resh now when resh comes down
garland tries to shoot him resch shoots
him instead they've killed the android
and now the question is
what next
what are we going to do
and
um
there's really several things
that are coming up here
so um
they've realized that the building is as
you know android
infested and they're going to sneak out
as it was what they do but
rash has a moment of
you could call it clarity but also
something like
horror
he says
i can't get over it it doesn't seem
possible
for three years i've been working under
the direction of androids
why didn't i suspect i mean enough to do
something and then
deckard says well maybe it's not that
long
they maybe they only recently
infiltrated this building right because
garland hasn't been around that long
and then rash said or yeah here he goes
he says they've been here all the time
garland has been my superior from the
start throughout my three years
and then rick says according to it the
bunch of them came to earth together and
that wasn't as long as three years it's
only been a matter of months and then
phil says this
then at one time an authentic garland
existed
and somewhere along the way
got replaced
his shark-like lean face twisted as he
struggled to understand
or
here so he's got a dilemma
i've been impregnated with a false
memory system maybe i only remember
garland over the whole time but
only androids show up with false memory
systems it's been found ineffective in
human beings
so phil rash either has been working at
a fake police station
not knowing that there was another
police station and this fake police
station by the way garland tells them
he says this is a homeostatic enterprise
we're operating here deckard we're a
closed loop cut off from the rest of san
francisco we know about them but they
don't know about us sometimes an
isolated person such as yourself wanders
in here or as in your case is brought
here for our protection now how is it
that smart phil rash
hasn't noticed that
the alternative is
he's actually an android
and he's had false memories implanted
and an android just killed another
android and is going to come along and
help kill yet another android and this
is very problematic isn't it now they
they do manage to escape the mission
street hall of justice uh you know by
pretending that deckard is a prisoner by
propping up garland at his desk by
tapping the intercom and saying
inspector garland is not to be bothered
for the next hour so they managed to get
out of the mission street hall of
justice but it still leaves
a lot of questions open
both for the characters who raised those
questions is phil rush and android or
not
but also for the rest of us us readers
there's larger open questions how is a
place like this able to
manage what what about these time
discrepancies
that we're noticing and dick never does
end up clarifying those matters
you